dans les années 70 la france découvre le
reggae un nouveau genre musical débarqué
de jamaïque
pourtant c'est un rythme enfin en quelle
je crois personnellement et un rythme
qui semble intéressant pour l'année à
venir pour vous qui sortez peut-être
pour vous qui avez reconnu actuellement
sur l'écran et entendu bob marley le
fameux roi du reggae avec sa chanson
qu'on entend sont toutes les radios qui
s'appelle exodus bob marley la figure du
reggae les français pour sa connaissance
ainsi que celle de jimmy cliff
et du groupe de six marines rythme
lancinant parole poétique sur fond de
discours religieux et politiques
le reggae se propage dans le monde
entier en 1978 bob marley de passage à
paris
sa musique son art de vivre attisé la
curiosité des journalistes français
alors pour vous bob marley est ce que le
reggae est un mythe un rythme une
religion ou tout simplement une danse
nous aimerions savoir votre avis
ça y est la philosophie reggae ses
sonorités vont inspirer des artistes
français comme serge gainsbourg
shir ali
les temps leur sens lens 2
sf mar
aux armes et caetera une adaptation de
la marseillaise sur un air de reggae la
chanson est enregistrée en quelques
jours en jamaïque
dès sa sortie en france en 1979 elle
créait la polémique
serge gainsbourg la marseillaise en
reggae c'est pas un peu de la
provocation
je pense pas je pense que le reggae est
une musique révolutionnaire la mairie
éric un chant révolutionnaire
après serge gainsbourg le reggae
inspirera d'autres artistes
un emblème jamaïcain classé aujourd'hui
au patrimoine immatériel de l'humanité
par l'unesco
[Musique]